now the Ukrainian President says he's
had his first phone call with the
Chinese leader since the start of the
war Vladimir zielinski described his
conversation with Xi Jinping as long and
meaningful she met Russian President
Vladimir Putin in Moscow last month
Beijing says it's maintaining neutrality
in the conflict
well we'll get more from Charles
Stratford in just a moment from his in
the Ukrainian Capital cave but first
let's go to Beijing and speak to Jessica
Washington she's there for us Jessica
president she seems to be styling
himself as quite the global Peacemaker
these days
well that's exactly right and that
context that you mentioned that these
are the first talks since the Russian
invasion of Ukraine between the two
leaders and that context that President
XI has met is Russian counterparts
several times including in person in
Moscow since the invasion and we do know
that president zielinski has repeatedly
requested a meeting or some kind of
discourse with President XI it seems
that only a few hours ago that goal was
finally realized so let's take a look at
some of what was discussed according to
a statement from the Chinese foreign
minister foreign Ministry the mutual
respect for sovereignty and territorial
integrity was something that both
leaders agreed upon as being the
political foundation of the relationship
between the two countries and what
president XI stressed according to this
statement is that China stands on the
side of Peace according to this
statement from the foreign Ministry all
relevant parties must stay calm and
exercise restraint now if we take a look
at this statement which details what was
discussed what the words that aren't
mentioned are as important as those that
are mentioned what we see is that the
words war and even any mention of Russia
have not been specifically mentioned if
we take a look at the outcomes from this
from this one hour phone call according
to what officials have said from the
Ukrainian perspective they have finally
appointed an ambassador to China after
the opposition had been vacant since
February of 2021 and from China's
perspective they have appointed us they
will appoint a special representative of
the Chinese government on Eurasian
Affairs who will be sent to Ukraine and
other countries it's not specified in
that statement which countries that
might include
Jessica Washington there with the latest
for us from Beijing thank you so much
Jessica well let's get the view from
Kiev now and speak to Charles Stratford
Charles there's been a perception
particularly with the presidential
visits and all that Beijing has been
perhaps a little more promoscow despite
its insistence that it's neutral does
this maybe Mark a shift
I don't think that anybody can doubt the
significance of this telephone
conversation it's a conversation that
zielinski has been asking for for a long
time
but there is also of course a lot of
Doubt certainly amongst the ukrainians
and many of their Western allies as to
whether China could ever be an honest
Arbiter in any kind of future peace
negotiations because of China's strong
relationship with Russia of course we
saw XI in Moscow last month
um talking about his dear friendship
with Vladimir Putin and we've seen this
12-point so-called peace plan that the
Chinese put together and they talk about
things like sovereignty in that plan now
zelinski when that was released on
February the 24th it just basically
denounced it as not being a peace plan
at all and very interestingly in the
last few minutes on his telegram Channel
he has released a statement and he talks
basically let me just pull it up for you
here he says that um
there will be no peace at the expense of
or of territorial compromise and that is
in direct relation serious we understand
to this telephone conversation so he
says there's been no peace at the
expense of territorial compromise he
said that no one wants peace more than
the Ukrainian people we are on our land
and we are fighting for our future
um so therein is an indication of you
know culling any kind of optimism that
despite this being of huge significance
we are a long way off this kind of uh
conversation this kind of relationship
the beginnings of it having any real
impact on on a future piece there is
still a long way to go just to let you
know there has been some International
reaction as well there's been some
reaction from the white house uh The
Rock The White House a spokesperson John
Kirby saying that it was good news but
um there was still far too it was still
far too early to to to note whether This
was um anywhere near
presenting the conditions for for a
peaceful solution to this war Charles
Stratford there in the Ukrainian capital
for us thank you Charles